find your passion
successful businesses are built around
entrepreneurs who are intensely
passionate about what they're doing
and they build the business up around it
if you do not follow your passion if
you're just trying to be successful
you're just trying to make money it's
never going to happen you will not have
success
you're going to go after failure after
failure after failure trying to jump on
the next quick money-making opportunity
and it's never going to work out because
you are not passionate about the product
or service that you're selling it's
critical it's everything it's the number
one rule in business
no strategy can save you if you're not
passionate about what you're selling
i got a question from a reader
uh ann keat who wrote in the same
he wants to start a business and so he
wanted my advice and and i wrote back to
say hey ankit what are you passionate
about and he said my passion is i want
to be successful
i want to have success that's not enough
that's not a true passion
and key you have to do something
that has the potential to change the
world you have to believe
so
firmly in what you're doing and that
it's the right thing to do
if you look at any successful famous
entrepreneur you look at how they got
started
it was not to make a ton of money
although that's a byproduct i'm not
saying start a charity i want you to
make a ton of money i want you to have a
ton of success
but it starts
with having a deep passion for something
it starts with you seeing a problem in
the world and wanting to change it
wanting to make it better
and everything flows from that
and you can share your passion you can
share your story and the people who will
buy from the people who will work for
you the people who will cover you in
media or investors they're going to come
because they believe in your passion
they believe in your vision
i believe in entrepreneurs i love
helping entrepreneurs it's my passion i
would help entrepreneurs even if i had
no way of making money from it and most
of the things i do like these videos i
don't make money from
i do it because
i love doing it i feel good doing it i
want to help entrepreneurs eighty
percent of companies fail
eighty percent of entrepreneurs
will have to shut down their companies
that's that's crazy to me to think about
the time and money and effort and energy
and everything you put into building a
company only to see it shut down
and it doesn't have to be that way and i
want to help these entrepreneurs get
past that
and i want to help you build a
successful company and build something
that you can be proud of
and it comes
from starting with a place of passion
you want to make a difference somewhere
in the world and when somebody asks you
what's your passion you have a clear
answer
it's not about you being successful it's
about doing something that matters
so what is that
and i believe that it's in there
i'm being hard on you but i believe that
that answer
is within you you just have to find it
a couple ways to help you do it
one think about
think about what you can get lost in
think about where you spend your time
what you could do for hours on end and
not notice that you've spent so much
time it's it's nine in the morning you
start and it's five at night and you
haven't even noticed that all that time
has gone by
you know i love helping entrepreneurs if
i'm in a meeting with an entrepreneur it
can go on for three four hours and i i
didn't even notice
because i love helping entrepreneurs
it's my passion
so find yours that's your first step
write down everything that you love
spending your time on
then two you got to match that up with
things that are add value
to
your customers
so a great way to think about it is what
frustrations have you solved for
yourself what was something that caused
you so much frustration pain suffering
in your life
that you had to solve like this is
unacceptable there's
i have this problem nobody solved it
so i'm gonna find a way to solve it for
myself
if you've done that chances are there
are other people who've had the same
problem and you can help them with it
so help them solve that problem
they'll be grateful they're looking for
an answer just like you would and you're
making it easy for them that's the
foundation of any successful business
and your third step to have a lot of
success is you got to match up
what you're passionate about what's
important
with what is offering
huge value to your customers
you match those two things up and you're
going to have a highly successful
business
you want to make a lot of money you want
to be really successful offer tons of
value to your customers you want to make
a lot of money quickly offer a lot of
value quickly to your customers
i want you to have success
and i know it's hard
it's hard not thinking about the dollars
you know it's hard when you're when
you're broke when you're trying to make
ends meet when you have kids and when
you're
you're struggling just to get by you
know you're thinking
i need money to pay the rent next week
you know like you gotta have cash i get
that
but if you want to have massive success
if that's your goal you want to make an
impact
you need to build a business around
something that you are intensely
passionate about and you'll make money
the money will come i promise you
if you just try to chase the next
money-making opportunity you're gonna
end up spending more time more dollars
more of the best years of your life
wasted on something
that is not going to work no matter what
people promise you
please don't make that mistake
and start a business around something
that you feel you can really have an
impact with
believe
thank you everybody for watching if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up below it really makes me want to do
more for you and i'd love to hear what
you have to think please leave a comment
underneath let me know what you think
you liked the video if you didn't like
the video and if you have a question for
your company leave it below i'll answer
for you i love making video responses
thank you guys i'll see you soon
you